I am live we are going to talk about the
Trump immigration ban stopped for now
I'm going to wait a second just to allow
people to connect and then I'm going to
get started and talk about it if people
have questions you can put them in the
comments what else should I be saying
about this I guess that's it we have a
super chat enabled and that's something
you can use if you want the comments
yesterday we're just moving so quickly
that they were almost completely useless
and so we have super chat enabled if you
definitely want me to see your comment
and may be respond to it if it's not
obvious trolling you can use the super
chat function so yeah I mean so much
news happening today after we were done
with today's show and part of the big
news over the last 24 hours is the Trump
immigration ban stay up held by the
Ninth Circuit and I think that judging
from the messages i'm getting on social
media there's a little bit of confusion
about what actually was decided by the
Ninth Circuit and what this means this
basically means that this initial
temporary period of the immigration ban
is going to remain suspended but this is
a totally separate thing from whatever
is going to be the permanent ban attempt
that we're going to see that we were
going to see no matter what after this
initial period so this is no doubt a
victory I mean obviously this is a
victory I've been talking about what I
see is not only the illegality but also
just the lack of sort of common sense of
this ban when you look at I won't rehash
it all now but looking at the countries
that were included the actual sources of
terror in the United States over who
knows how many years etc when you
actually look at that the ban just made
absolutely no sense but there's going to
be a whole other battle and we already
heard from from Trump that next week
there's going to be more news or
decisions or announcements related to
security I don't know exact
what that means yet and also again
eventually this this means the temporary
ban remain suspended we will eventually
see some something else and this it's
really important to mention at this
point something I've been talking about
for a while which is if the eventual
permanent ban proposal is uh slightly
less crazy than this initial one we have
to remember to still analyze it on its
merits at the time and not just to sort
of sit back and say well we won because
what he eventually passed is not as
crazy as that initial thing that was
staged by a number of appeals courts
including the Ninth Circuit it's really
important not to be lulled into thinking
that there's been some kind of victory
if what is eventually passed or proposed
by tom is ninety percent as insane as
the most recent ban attempt which we now
know is is not going to be happening
okay hi to everybody who is watching
live I've just been sampling since
YouTube turned on mobile live streaming
streaming from my phone yesterday it
went well going to talk about a few
different issues that are going on today
I will try to also answer questions from
the chat it often moves very very
quickly consider using the super chat
function which will put your comment at
the very top for a while I've no clue
really how it works but we've turned it
on and uh people are telling me lots of
people just tremendously smart people
are telling me that it's a it's a good
thing or something like that uh okay a
couple other things I want to talk about
related to the immigration ban one is
this idea that when the term Muslim ban
is used there are some trumpets and some
so-called skeptics call them whatever
you want right does doesn't matter there
are people who don't like the idea of
calling it a Muslim ban because they say
hey this is an immigration ban and it
nationality based it's not religion
based and thus it is not a Muslim ban I
agree with you that the name that's been
assigned is is not this is a Muslim ban
but we know number one that Donald Trump
went to rudy giuliani and said hey I
want to do a Muslim ban help me figure
out how to do it so that it'll be legal
that's number one and number two even if
it's not officially a Muslim ban look at
the language of it right we're selecting
muslim-majority nations and Donald Trump
said that after the test period call it
what you will he's open to allowing
refugees to come from those countries as
long as they are religious minorities so
again who is targeted by saying we will
only allow refugees who are in the
religious minority from Muslim majority
countries Muslims so I think it's a
total semantics game and I know a lot of
people are pointing me to the dave rubin
video where dave rubin says hey this is
not actually a Muslim ban and dave rubin
is completely right i watch that video i
believe in its entirety has been a few
days now since i saw it and he says hey
I looked at the text of it it's not a
Muslim man in the literal sense and dave
rubin is completely right but reasonable
people can't really deny that this is
the UH the objective of this batch okay
some people are talking about some kind
of clicking I don't know if you're
referring to me or I don't know what
Clifton people are referring to am I
clicking now I'm not click training
people as someone is suggesting there oh
I'm hitting my microphone hmm well I
don't mean to do that uh I apologize I
know I can't this would be very
uncomfortable to hold this up in front
of me like this people suggesting I open
the phone lines I don't know how I would
do that I don't know what with the
technical aspect of doing that when I'm
just streaming from my phone is okay
what else did I want to discuss with
regard to the Muslim ban which I'm
completely comfortable
uh calling it uh what is eventually
going to be proposed I don't know it
again my sense has been that there's
been an attempt to use these shock
events and then to try to pass something
that is 85 90 or 95 percent as crazy and
have it slip under the radar so I would
anticipate that what is ultimately
proposed is going to be very very
similar to what what was proposed and
did not really work well um okay people
saying talk about justice Democrats I
talked about justice Democrats yesterday
to the extent that i am familiar with it
and so I'm not going to do again because
i did that yesterday and i don't think
i'm going to talk about that again that
that's one thing so a lot of comments
about that a lot of people still saying
that there's some kind of clicking going
on I there's no clip for me to clip onto
my shirt so I don't know that that's
something I can do maybe i'll just try
holding this out a little bit right now
my mic is hitting something yeah here's
something interesting what do I think
about Howard Stern's comment that Trump
is must be wishing Hillary Clinton won
yeah I've been listening to howard stern
for a long time and I heard him talk
about what was his at some point
friendship with Donald Trump etc and I
found it very very interesting and I I
think it's pretty reasonable to think
that Donald Trump maybe is not loving
what's going on right now we know he's
super thin skinned we know he's
incredibly bothered by just the basic
things that any high-level politician
has to deal with parodies Saturday Night
Live criticisms etc guy's a billionaire
whether he has 4 10 billion or whatever
doesn't really matter 70 years old I i
if I were him I don't know that I'd want
to be President of the United States and
if I started it as a publicity thing I
think it's very reasonable to think that
I would be saying you know I can't
really quit but I'm not really loving
this
uh so I i I'd who knows what's in
Trump's mine but I think Howard Stern's
comments were were pretty reasonable uh
and uh it trop Trump seems increasingly
unhinged increasingly confused we've
been talking about his uh sort of
questionable literacy rate and reading
level etc so yeah I think if you told me
wow we found we found out that Trump
doesn't really want to be President I'd
say yeah obviously why would that that
makes absolutely perfect sense to me uh
okay as far as next week let me tell you
what's going on next week on the show
people have suggested that when we're in
sort of like pre production mode in the
studio that I do a live stream and show
people what's going on in there uh I
would love to do that you know the thing
is the pre-production time is like 10
a.m. eastern time 11 a.m. eastern time
and that's not an ideal time for live
streams it's really early on the west
coast um and uh I don't know I mean I'll
do it I'll do it and show people what
goes on maybe do a studio tour etc I
would love to do that I just don't know
that it's going to do super well because
of the time of day that that goes on as
far as stories I'm looking at for next
week we've got a bunch of interviews
lined up but we'll talk about that maybe
later I I do want to talk about this
there's a couple Russia related things
that are going on number one there's
sort of drama right now because mike
pence after the election but before the
inauguration of the entire Trump regime
cadre call it what you will group of
low-information grifters after that Mike
Pence was asked whether michael Flynn
national security adviser spoke to the
Russian ambassador about sanctions and
that would be completely inappropriate
problematic in so many ways that I won't
even dig into now what will on monday
and Mike Pence said absolutely not there
were no discussions during that
conversation of sanctions now we've more
recently heard from Mike Flynn
actually doesn't remember whether there
were conversations about sanctions or
not there's this really cringe-worthy
video of mike flynn shaking hands with
mike pence uh recently and it was to say
it was hostile is is definitely an
understatement uh and this this could be
a major problem now for the trump
administration from an ethics
perspective there's just a lot of real
questions and again russia keeps coming
up the other funny story that i'm
looking at if I pull up here for for the
monday show is about a report that
Donald Trump had to ask aids what is the
nuclear treaty with Russia uh during
that infamous call with Vladimir Putin
that we now are unsure if the recording
equipment was turned off or not or what
whatever the hell it was that went on
there there's a report that Donald Trump
had to ask hey guys what's this nuclear
treaty with Russia that Vladimir Putin
keeps referring to which is disturbing
to say the least no doubt about that and
definitely on Monday I'll be talking
about the there's now a report from
Homeland Security this is an internal
report that we've now seen about this
big beautiful wall that Donald Trump
says he's going to build we we had a
initial estimates reasonable estimates
right not from the Trump campaign but
reasonable estimates from people who
know about this who said that it would
cost somewhere between 10 and 12 billion
and there's a new report now that's been
leaked according to Reuters a homeland
security report that it would be a 22
billion dollar project and that it would
basically be done maybe maybe
optimistically by the end of trumps
first term it would take three and a
half years to build so that would be a
major thing hey we have our first super
chat super chat from sleepy Stu who for
two dollars has had his comment featured
okay who gets that two dollars I mean I
I would assume we do but I've never seen
any I have no idea how super chat works
saying will you do an interview with
Andrew McAfee of MIT uh okay well let's
take that seriously I don't know offhand
exactly what his area of expertise is
the business impact of IT he is part of
the MIT initiative on the digital
economy it sounds very interesting I
would absolutely be interested in
interviewing Andrew McAfee or mcafee I'm
not exactly sure how he pronounces his
name named one of the 100 most
influential people in IT yes I will
leave that up on my screen and I will
look into I will look into that thank
you for using the super chat I
appreciate it okay and then what else am
I looking at for Monday yo I saw scroll
by in the chat here a couple different
things that I do want to address one is
have I talked about or am i aware of
Kellyanne Conway promoting Ivanka
Trump's stuff and yes I am aware of that
and I'm absolutely absolutely going to
be talking about that on on Monday and
one other thing I mentioned this
yesterday that there's this new report
from the Guardian saying that
misinformation is leaning left under
Donald Trump and I've still not looked
at it in huge detail but I plan to and I
plan to report on that as well and you
know I have no reason whatsoever to hide
that if that's the truth I will
absolutely report on it suggestions that
sam Harris be on the program like I
mentioned yesterday we've invited sam
Harris he hasn't responded would love to
absolutely have a mom that would be
really great shout out to Frances marks
who just signed up for a David Pakman
show membership during the live stream
someone who is watching the live stream
and has signed up for a six dollar a
month subscription thank you thank you
so much yes membership the number one
funding source for the show and if you
need a discount if the normal membership
prices are high use the coupon code I
voted 17 that that's fine I don't care
if you're paying six dollars a month or
three dollars a month used
code and helps us keep going what it is
that we were doing here shoutouts
forthcoming for anybody who signs up for
membership during the live stream okay
sort of a sports / Boston story there
are some new england patriots the
superbowl 51 winning new england
patriots who were going to be skipping
the visit to the White House and I'll
probably talk about that I'm a big
Patriots fan the show is broadcast here
from Boston so I will address that
usually it's scheduling conflicts I
haven't looked at it in detail yet but I
have that story bookmarked Super Bowl li
yeah super bowl 50 one that's that's the
same thing right 51 and and Li people
asking what membership does you get a
commercial free audio and video stream
everyday of the entire show instead of
three to five minute clips on YouTube
you get a one-hour minus the commercial
so it's like 50 minutes one video file
one hour no commercials and we also do
something called the bonus show every
single day it's like an extra 15 20
minutes show just for our paid
subscribers we do stories a lot more
behind-the-scenes stuff is discussed
their upcoming stuff on the show all
that type of stuff okay so that's what
that's the deal that's the deal with
membership and on that note shout out to
Luis Cruz who has just uh signed up for
a David Pakman show membership using the
coupon code and uh thank you thank you
to Luis really really appreciate it um
okay couple other things from the chat
again people saying please talk about
justice Democrats I don't know that much
about justice Democrats I did talk about
it during yesterday's live stream to the
extent that I'm I'm aware of it I talked
about it yesterday I was texting a
little bit with Kyle kolinsky a few days
ago about doing an interview about it
and uh hopefully we can line that up
pretty soon okay
shins about what's going on with uh my
feelings on the Tom Brady relationship
with Donald Trump I still don't know
what the the extent of that relationship
is I know not that this is the the big
the big thing that a lot of people are
worried about here but um Giselle uh his
wife tweeted or put something on
Instagram you know what I don't even
know I don't know what the deal is but I
vaguely remember gizelle saying that
they're not as a family voting for Trump
or whatever I don't know I don't know
what's going on with that thank you too
Shawn Hoyt who has just created a new
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership using the forty percent
coupon code uh I voted 17 oh and there
is Sean there is Sean in the comments
great to see Sean uh quite a handsome
picture that sean has there as his
google image there boom yes Jean Hoyt
welcome welcome welcome I could I think
we I don't know if Sean Hoyt just
created a second membership I could have
sworn we already had a member named uh
Sean Hoyt and also thank you to someone
going by the name of Red Baron Red Baron
just creating a membership without the
coupon code at david pakman.com slash
membership okay longform pieces that
were working on you may remember that in
january of 2016 we debuted the first
long-form piece that the david pakman
show did it was researched and a
background research done by none other
than former intern and now segment and
associate producer Noah Ferguson on Reza
Aslan okay Reza Aslan cannot be trusted
was the name of that since then in
partnership with Noah's great work we've
done a number of other long-form pieces
including about undocumented immigration
the all right the regressive left etc
etc I was just emailing with Noah
and currently we are working on a
long-form piece on um gerrymandering
okay and I've been saying many many
times progressives can't just wait till
2020 now and then say hey now we're
gonna win everything and deal with the
entire thing right we've got stuff going
on in 2017 we've got the 2018 elections
and we have a census in 2020 and we have
to be prepared for what the implications
of that census are with regard to
gerrymander we're also seeing at the
state level a certain congressional
district drawing that has been
completely shut down the way that guy
Todd akin thought a woman's body did to
prevent her from being becoming pregnant
if she's raped that was crazy but we
actually have judges were saying hey the
way some of these districts are drawn
makes no sense so in order to get people
thinking about that we are working on a
long-form piece of myself and Noah
Ferguson we're working on that with
gerrymandering and I think that will be
a really really good piece shout out to
James Logan who has just created a
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership with the forty percent
discount code i voted 17 thank you to
James for doing that uh not seeing James
in the comments here but uh there is you
betcha James Logan checking in there
absolutely now gets instant access to
all of the great stuff that we're doing
other long-form pieces um but let me
just interject people still asking about
justice Democrats I was asked this
yesterday during the live stream I know
a little bit about it uh I'm working
with Kyle kolinsky to do an interview
about it but I don't I don't know
everything about it and I don't really
have anything to to comment on beyond
saying that there needs to be some um
force within the Democratic Party to
move the Democratic Party to the left
okay so i will hopefully be able to get
kyle kolinsky on soon and we'll be able
to talk about that okay long-form pieces
i see someone talking about
shima radiation that's interesting i'm
going to make a note of that along with
the suggestion from earlier about
interviewing Andrew McAfee from MIT the
idea of a these live streams are really
bringing a lot of good ideas to the show
very very useful the idea of a long-form
piece about Fukushima radiation that's a
very very good idea generally speaking
if you have ideas that lend themselves
to longer form more researched and
investigative type pieces tweet me email
me you can post them to our reddit
discussion forum at david pakman.com
slash reddit etc etc ok so that always
good always good to get suggestions from
the audience I will tell you some of the
people it's a little risky to say this
because some of these interviews may not
happen but here are some of the people
that I'm talking to about coming on the
david pakman show for an interview
Ronald fry is a former a military
captain who actually lived among in
Muslim communities in the Middle East
and it was a totally different approach
to fighting terror in the sense of sort
of antipathy towards the united states
in the West and I'm super interested in
interviewing him he did a reddit AMA
recently which was really interesting
also Stefan I think genet or a guy
Annette GUI Annette is someone who is an
expert on sort of the way in which food
affects the body in ways that can be
similar to drugs like sugar for example
i'm really really interested in talking
to him and also back by popular demand
peter bogosian peter bogosian who is a
critical thinking and sort of a skeptic
rationalist thinker is going to be
joining me on the show actually this
week we got that put together very very
quickly so that is a interview i'm
looking forward to and also people
suggested there's this guy named Andrew
Torres who's an attorney and
he has a legal related podcast called
open opening arguments or open arguments
I think its opening arguments he's going
to be on the show this coming week as
well so I'm really really looking
forward to that okay big shout out to
Joseph Bisbee who just created a
40-percent discounted membership again
with that coupon code I mentioned a few
minutes ago I voted 17 at david
pakman.com opting to go with the yearly
version thirty-six bucks for the year
instead of 60 Joseph Bisbee thank you
very very much and that coupon code is
open to all also this I'm really really
looking forward to I don't know how many
people who are watching right now are
familiar with Professor Kent green field
from the Boston College School of Law he
is a guy who has written very very
interesting books brilliant brilliant
guy and he is also going to be on the
show and I really look forward to having
him on if you just Google Kent
greenfield boston college you'll find a
lot of information about Kent greenfield
and when is he going to be on ok so the
schedule is Monday we've got Kent
greenfield scheduled tuesday actually
we're going to do a two-part interview
with Peter bogosian because there's just
so much to talk about with him will do
part one on tuesday valentine's day part
two on wednesday and then thursday we've
got Andrew Torres on which this is a
good week this is a good week as far as
interviews go and then this I think some
people will also like luke vargas has
reported in with us for us it's got to
be like nine or 10 different countries
around the world at this point and he's
going to be joining us the week of the
21st from Mexico where he's actually
going to be going to factories in Mexico
talking to business owners about this
proposal that Donald Trump has for a
20-percent tariff and I think that that
is going to be super super interesting
okay I'll take some specific questions
the live chat we have super chat enabled
for people who want to absolutely make
sure that they're common to seeing we
had one super chat which suggested
Andrew McAfee as an interview guests big
shout out before I get to that too wow
this is not a name that is easy for me
to pronounce I believe I don't want to
be offensive but the first name might be
lassie or loss I'm not sure lost lada
forget ledee fo'get laid forget a
difficult difficult name to say but what
I can be sure is that loss used the
coupon code I voted 17 and got forty
percent off their membership i don't
know if that's a man's name or woman's
name uh at david pakman.com slash
membership uh a few questions about
whether sargon of akkad as i know i know
him as Carl Benjamin um questions about
whether Carl Benjamin responded to my
video saying he had called me out for
click bait but he's using click bait he
hasn't and I i don't i'm not surprised i
think that that was one of those
situations where I'm inferring here but
Carl I would guess felt like that if he
responded he was giving me more
attention than he wanted to and and you
know I sort of get that sometimes I
don't respond to people because I just
don't want to give any more attention to
what they're doing so no he did not
respond interestingly though someone
sent me a screenshot on Twitter the
other day saying that Sargon put out a
video called the assassination of Donald
Trump saying if anything is a hyperbolic
title it's calling something the
assassination of Donald Trump but it was
a screenshot i did not independently
confirm that okay so uh yes Sargon has
not responded people asking if I am a
drummer yes I live in an apartment
building now where I can't have my full
drums so all i have here is that's a
snare drum and then i put three practice
pads on top of it
uh in order to quiet it down and on the
floor you can kinda see on the floor
there it's a variety of drum books these
are the ones uh these are the ones that
you know sort of practice pad work that
you can do uh couple people suggesting
an electronic drum set yeah I just don't
even have room for it I mean I that's an
idea that you play with headphones very
very good idea uh but just don't really
have room for here unfortunately um okay
big thank you to Michael beavers who has
just also used coupon code I voted 17 to
become a member of david pakman.com
slash membership and also big thank you
to laura mule Howser who is just bought
david pakman show coffee yet the coffee
is happening now i just got an email
today where we roast we have the david
pakman show coffee blends are roasted
very close to boston in hopedale
massachusetts by blue fire coffee
roasters and um i got an email earlier
today from patrick maloney who runs the
company really good guy and he was
saying you know this this coffee thing
is going really well so far we've only
been doing it for about 48 hours and a
lot of coffee people seeming I guess
people drink coffee you know that's uh
that's a good thing people asking if the
birthday coupon code is still active for
a 33 dollar a year membership it is the
coupon code is 33 today you can still
use that some people asking me in
different ways shapes and forms how is
Donald Trump getting away with
everything that he's doing I've said
this before and I'll say it again let me
just have a little water here Donald
Trump violating the Constitution does
not automatically trigger any
repercussions whatsoever okay if we
believe Donald Trump is in violation of
the emoluments clause for example
because of conflicts of interest someone
has to act on that and we have a
Republican House and we have a
Republican Senate
so there's no switch that is flipped the
moment Trump does something that's
against the law in violation of the
Constitution that brings repercussions
Kellyanne Conway known to some as
Kellyanne conned me uh she may have
broken the law as an official White
House advisor to to the president by
suggesting people by Ivanka Trump's
clothing line after Nordstrom's decided
to stop carrying it unless someone does
something about it think about it this
way robbing a convenience store is a
crime but unless you're charged with the
crime you will never be convicted of the
crime right the law as downstream oh one
is saying in the chat here the law
doesn't matter unless it's enforced okay
that's absolutely and exactly right so I
think that that is a something we just
have to realize to sit back and say hey
you know what Trump's breaking the law
he's violating this is violating that
it's all going to be taken care of
eventually know that it does not happen
automatically shout out and thank you
too Amanda Fleck Amanda fleck has signed
up for a discounted membership at david
pakman.com slash membership using the
coupon code i voted 17 thank you thank
you very much we have our next super
chat from richie maineville who has paid
in canadian dollars that's fine with me
we apparently youtube accept Canadian
currency saying will I interview slug
physic absolutely I've tried to get him
on the show before he has not responded
it would be absolutely fantastic to
interview mr. suszek on the show if
anybody can help make that happen then I
would absolutely love to do it I don't
know what else we can do other than
tweeting him or emailing him neither
which we heard back from I don't know
what else we can really do as far as
that goes so if people have ideas about
that let me know and we will we will try
to get them on okay a few other
questions from people
here I saw something a little bit
further up in the questions about my
opinion of what's going on more broadly
with left media and issues of you know
free speech the type of stuff Dave
Rubens went been talking about and so on
and so forth a lot of people want me to
sort of draw a line in the sand it seems
between what seems to be a sort of I
don't even know what to call it is it is
it a battle is it a some kind of
disagreement that's going on between the
views of the young turks tyt network
call them what you will and Dave Ruben
Ruben report etc I'm not following it so
closely that I can even say with
certitude that that's even a sort of a
battle that that's going on but you know
I watched some a day of Rubens videos
and I hear a lot that I agree with and I
hear things that I don't agree with I
think that there's a difference between
objectivity and neutrality so when it
comes to something like you know people
email me they say did you see how dave
rubin brought on x person and allowed
them to just present their views
unopposed I think that who exper ssin is
actually makes a difference because if
we're talking about political opinion
right someone's philosophy so to speak
um bringing someone on and taking the
dave rubin approach which is hey i'm
here to learn about and hear about your
views I'm not necessarily here to play
point counterpoint with you on
everything or to get into some kind of
fight with you know argument or whatever
that that does make sense to me and
there's interviews I've done in fact
where the person's views are so out
there and ridiculous that there's really
no point to be playing point
counterpoint because we're just going to
get bogged down let's sort of learn what
their general of philosophy is on the
other side if we're talking about
science right and you bring on a
climate-science denier who is in the
exponential minority when it comes to uh
uh what what the sign says about climate
science that's not an interview where
I'd be comfortable allowing someone to
just talk about their views unopposed um
so that I have I have more of a problem
with right so I don't have a problem
broadly with this idea of hey bring
people on and let them let them talk
rather than then aggressively debating
really don't have a problem that uh but
I think when it comes to to science it's
uh definitely more problematic okay now
as far as tyt i watch very little of of
almost anything really i mean i'm mostly
reading and when i'm finding out about
things that have happened on different
shows it's because i'm reading a
transcript of it i really have very
little time to actually sit down and
watch stuff so i'm not exactly sure what
specifically that's been going on on tyt
people are reacting to and having a
problem with but i'm glad to look into
it if people get in touch with me about
it you know I my youtube channel was
part of tyt network for a while
separated under completely friendly
terms i see Jenk and steve and and aaron
and all the guys once or twice a year at
Mike Papantonio conference in Las Vegas
and I have you know no problem defending
or criticizing ideas right and and
that's very very different than an ad
hominem thank you to Sean Troxel who has
just made an order of david pakman show
coffee through the website roasted by
blue fire coffee roasters also thank you
to heather gilding who has taken
advantage of the yeah i had my birthday
on februari second and we had a coupon
code that started that day it's 33 today
and that gives you a sixty-dollar
membership for thirty-three dollars and
heather gilding taking advantage of that
I think she was the person in the chat
asking about whether that was still
available all right am I still wearing
pants yes i am i am i am wearing pants
currently a sort of an odd question but
you know i guess if you couldn't
they couldn't see you wouldn't
necessarily know somebody suggesting
that was interesting what was this
comment uh if I don't have time install
video speed controller and watch shows
at a very high speed you know who does
that my friend Jay Tomlinson the
producer of best of the left podcast he
told me that he listens he was at one
point listening to shows i think at one
point two x and then went to 1.4 x and
said that there's even some shows that
he can listen to at 2x and doesn't have
any problem whatsoever so that's
interesting yeah I've not thought of
that I can usually just kind of skim a
transcript of something of more quickly
than anything else liam says this is a
[ __ ] show all right you know it's always
good to throw in 11 a trolling comment
I'm an Eastern American timezone to
answer Matt's question here in Boston
Massachusetts it is quite stinky here
Stephen grayer has just done a
five-dollar super chat comment but the
comment is blank I guess Stephen just
felt like sending five bucks uh all
right well thank you stephen would it
would have been glad to take a question
from you but i guess just sending the
five bucks very cool okay i'm not snowed
in i'm about to go in fact i'm going to
an argentinian gathering there's a group
of fellow argentineans here in
massachusetts in the boston area getting
together tonight i am bringing read
argentinian malbec which i've been told
is very very peppery for anybody who
cares about that there will be empanadas
and it should be a really really good
time one last thank you to Georgia
cosenza who just used the I voted 17
coupon code to sign up for a membership
at david pakman.com slash membership
Richie asking if I am vegan I am not
vegan I am NOT vegan i am not vegetarian
either i eat basically no red meat at
this point very very frequently i eat
red meat I poultry I eat fish and
seafood etc etc
dairy products make cappuccinos most
mornings and I use real whole milk last
super chat also now coming in from Ian
saying do I follow sam Harris do I know
of his critics arguments yeah I read a
lot of the arguments against sam Harris
that he's Islamophobic that he is uh
just generally you know but a lot of
different criticisms about sam Harris
and I don't know what else to say about
it i would i would love to interview sam
Harris but he is unfortunately not
responded alright that's it for today
I'll try to do a studio tour on Monday
when I get into the studio